皆さん視力どうですか女まあ僕だか塩と酢をパソコンを見たりゲームで自分がすごい
長いんでだんだん音が悪くなってきてるんでたぶんねほんとはね金かけなきゃいけない
ぐらいの主力になってるんですよコンタクトは怖くてできないけどね知力復活させる
ならねえんだねーんだということで今回子連れを買ってきました
っぽい
十分外して買ったからわかんないかせめて買ったからわかんないんですけど
メガネを買いましたでこのメガネがすごいんです続けます
[音楽]
おおおおこれかあいこのみんなが何か普通のメガネっぽく見えるんですけどもうなんと
このメガネェ
絶対に外れないメガネらしいで絶対かどうかはちょっと自信ないんですけどメガネつけ
てて不便だと思う時ってあると思うんですよそれってもなんか寝られて運動シャレなら
動いたりするとね外れるんですよねそれがやるんですけどもなどはこちらのメガネこ
れっ子
すごいなんか独特な形をしてますねフォローこちらのメガネですねなんと
つけれど外れなくなる願いらしいですよとしたらカクテキをもうこれつけながら走っ
たりときますからね
果たしてどういうスキュニョここがすごいくねくねしますこれでそれが両方に付いてる
感じですこれだけでもうね取れないんだろうつっます
イーマじゃねえっ
落ちない全く嘘でしょどういう仕組みな
どういう仕組みなのはもういますきてる感じだとまずで落ちないですね
ています
ねまたや同市と同シートすげー落ちないなんとコーチないと普通こういう動きでもを
釣る方まではなさそう
チョイスはどういう仕組みなんだろうなぁ爆ぜたこと床ってなってるんだがこれもなぜ
だななんか仕組みよくわかんないんですけど建物は彼と彼が何かうまいこと耳に
引っかかって完全に堕ちない仕組みになってるんでしょうねですやー
私の目バー
ああそう簡単に騙せない女だときには普通につけてブンブン振っても外せなかったん
ですけど果たして絶対外れないってどこまで外れないのかちょっと検証してみようと
思いますねよくあるともですねメディアに作ってるアレせると外れちゃうとあると思う
んですけども其の中に象生活で8日あるような目でね外れるシーンを今の実に行ってみ
てこんなメガネが本当に外れないかどうかを検証し
いきたいと思います釣ってない4 of 4
[音楽]
ああああああ
wh
いっ
はぁっ
なあ
命令
me
[音楽]
をグッ
すげー
wh
[音楽]
[拍手]
あああああん
[音楽]
わあああああああああ
car
uh
家についてよーっどっ
wh
[音楽]
[拍手]
パッ
[音楽]
いやー
すげー
[音楽]
とかうわあああああああ
5わー
ああああああ
[音楽]
3いやああああああああっ
me
dea
ana あああっ